We appear to want leaders who are charming and entertaining,...
...but there is a big difference between an effective leader and a stand-up comedian.
In fact, the best leaders are humble rather than charismatic,...
...to the point of even being rather boring.
This is why they rarely feature in the media or blockbuster movies.
For example, imagine a movie on Angela Merkel.
She wakes up, has breakfast with her husband,...
...goes to meetings well-prepared,...
...lets other people talk without interrupting them,...
...makes rational decisions, runs her country well.
There are no scandals about her.
In contrast, there is a surplus of captivating biopics...
...on charismatic leaders with a fascinating dark side,...
...who end up ruining their countries and organizations.